dann stehen auch schon wieder dass das
klappt ist hier jetzt könnt ihr alle
meine worin ich die ganze zeit auf
weiter douglas über ein wunderschöner
neuer tag erwartet uns hier in unserem
ein kraftfeld wie geht's dir da unten
wie die direkt vom grab war
heute ist ja die große höhlen folge
darauf müssen wir uns allerdings erst
ein bisschen vorbereiten und zwar bauen
wir dafür erst mal ein bisschen seetang
ab wir haben ganz viel in die kommentare
geschrieben das sich unter wasser
einfach doppelklick machen kann und dann
quasi unter wasser sprinter
beziehungsweise halt einfach richtig
schwimme hier so richtig über den
untergrund uns weiter und so fort und
mit die scheiße ist das mein arzt gesagt
hatte ich dafür nicht aufregen weil ich
mache gerade ein langzeit-ekg jetzt gehe
ich hier schon wieder runter
so haben wir den ganzen kram zimmer
eingesammelt ich kann doch noch mal eben
schnell hier vorne den ball
wir konzentrieren uns jetzt auf das ziel
für heute und zwar ist dass die höhlen
episode ja ich weiß auch nicht warum du
plötzlich fliegen ganz sie haben uns ja
schon in der letzten folge hier so eine
kleine minimale base gebaut wo wir
zumindest schon mal so ein bisschen was
rein packen können
ich hoffe jetzt mal ein bisschen seetang
rein den braten wir hiermit mal damit
wir auf dauer immer was zu essen haben
ich hab jetzt ich hab kein holz schöne
kiste mitgenommen
[Musik]
ich werde direkt abgeschossen das doch
nicht war aber für solche fälle habe ich
halt meinen bogen mitgenommen ich hasse
krieger sind das kripo songs gewesen
lach nicht so du bist gedroht
mein gott okay ich werde jetzt erstmal
in diese richtung hier ein bisschen
gehen hier eine fackel hinsetzen um ein
gott okay so tief sind wir schon wir
sind einfach auch verdammt lang
[Musik]
also das ging jetzt schnell mit den
diamanten
[Musik]
sehr gut danke nochmal für die ganzen
tipps mit der axt also das ist wirklich
deutlich besser als mit als mit der als
mit dem schwert es ist hier ist wirklich
extrem viel los das hat sich als top-
ligen wurden spona wer oder so
dieser kleine dass die einen immer
angreifen müssen immerhin dort aber
irgendwas geht hier ja anscheinend ab
irgendwas ist da los kunden sind so
viele monster
ich weiß nicht ob ich die ersten soll
oder ob ich erst so ein bisschen meinen
soll weil wir brauchen halt auf jeden
fall
wir brauchen auf jeden fall kohle für
fackeln damit ich ein bisschen mehr
ausleuchtet weil der o mein gott das ist
doch nicht wahr
die wollen mich doch alle verarschen
oder die wollen mich alle tot sehen wir
machen uns jetzt hier erstmal acht
fackeln denn wir haben viele leute auch
geschrieben dass ich einfach eine fackel
nehmen kann und die meine linke hand
nehmen kann ich will die allerdings
trotzdem so ein bisschen hier platzieren
damit ihr einfach keine weiteren
monsters bauen also hier sollte alles
clean sein hier ist auch noch ein
bisschen kohle die kann ich eben abbauen
sie irgendjemand glaubt die luft ist
rein mein gott da kommt direkt hier
stirbt mein gott ich habe zwei herzen
ich hab halt deine fresse
wir müssen glaube ich es einfach mal
wagen herunter zu gehen aber hier ist
halt komplett party das kann ich mir
eigentlich nicht erlauben oder via oder
wir gehen halt ganz langsam vor und
dachte das war definitiv keine gute idee
das war eine ganz bestimmte das war
richtig beschissen die idee könnte halt
theoretisch mal kurz den bogen raus
packen und selber so ein bisschen damit
spielen beziehungsweise um sie mal so
ein
deshalb suchen wir sind das okay das ist
wasser hier kommt glaube ich so schnell
kein gott da ist ein skelett schon ja
alter was ist denn das für ein skelett
lastigen es hier o mein gott das schön
auch schon wieder
[Musik]
ich spiele auf der schwierigkeit normal
und ich werde von dem ganzen spiel
und damit meine ich wirklich von dem
kompletten spiel wahrscheinlich sind die
hälfte meiner items runter gekullert ich
hab's genommen dass lapislazuli hier
es kann doch nicht sein von wo werde ich
hier abgeschossen von wo werde ich
abgeschossen wenn ihr stecken zwei teile
einer da halt und einem abend du kennst
du scheiße jetzt
jetzt ist es mir auch scheißegal was
dort passiert jetzt ist es mir wirklich
scheiße gehalten
jetzt könnt ihr alle meine ich war heute
beim kardiologen
ich habe das hier an meinem körper ein
langzeit-ekg ich soll ganz normal meinen
tag leben nicht mehr normal
wo kommt der her wo kommt der her
kann mir einer sagen wo dieser penner
herkommt ist darunter auch noch lava
halt schwerer da setzt sich extra eine
fackel neben dass wir wissen da ist lava
jeder reisen nehmen wir nicht ganz
entspannt ganz entspannt luca beruhigt
dich alles wird gut
alles wird gut das ist einfach nur
minecraft hülle alles easy alles easy
ich will hier kein monster aber ich lege
meine hand dafür ins feuer dass sobald
ich hier lang laufe von irgendwo einen
tripper oder ein skelett auftaucht los
geht's ich glaube einfach dass unser
problem das wasser hier darstellt
dadurch ist nämlich da unten
sowas habe ich noch nicht erlebt so
etwas habe ich noch
darunter leide welt alles klar
das hat doch wirklich wirklich nichts
mehr mit einer normalen minecraft runde
hier zu tun das ist doch einfach nicht
mehr normal
guck mal ich mache mir jetzt ein helm
einen brustpanzer ich mache mir dazu
noch eine hose und ich mache mir noch
schuhe dazu also mehr geht nicht an
rüstung laser luca 960 hat den
fortschritten macht sich fein erzielte
gleich macht diese scheiß spiel gleich
mal fein natürlich und natürlich
natürlich natürlich wenn auf dem prepaid
von hinten kommen das ist doch nicht war
natürlich trifft auf seinen ersten
schuss
natürlich trifft das ein zweiter schuss
alter das ist doch nicht mehr normal
ja selbstverständlich genau 23
okay der krieg ist tot
das heißt unser größtes ziel wäre der
uns am meisten schaden zufügen kann es
gestorben
zudem haben wir die rüstung leute ich
riskiere es jetzt ich gehe jetzt runter
ich drehe mich nicht um
ich möchte jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
raus okay das hier ist die situation von
der wir gerade unten waren und nach oben
geschaut haben und guck mal hier kann
wirklich aus jeder gott verdammt denke
du lässt mich die ganze zeit auf weiter
druck ausüben
trotzdem strahlt vox im strahl spiele
gehabt als betrieb abgeladen alter
das heißt ich an meinem magen wenn ich
zehn tagen nichts gegessen ab ist da was
ändern männern kommt um so kleiner
wieso wird er nicht direkt sterben wenn
ich den ok kann mal hier ich da mache
ich nichts du hast mir nichts getan
plus sender verloren
das ist du siehst aber ich bin auch ich
habe da wirklich einfach keinen bock
mehr drauf ich habe den ich ganz ehrlich
ich habe auf diese folge keinen bock
mehr dk ich ziehe jetzt diese rüstung an
dieser hier vorne der gesagt hat dass
ich aus wie ein stück scheiße alter du
kannst mich mal wie viel schaden macht
er denn er ist richtig sauer
der ist richtig sauer den garten
[Musik]
der hat erst richtig wütend habe ich
mich gerade selbst ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich wollte eigentlich noch als
erfolgserlebnis vor heute zumindest die
diamanten von da hinten holen aber das
geht nicht mehr legal
das geht nicht mehr ich kann das nicht
ich kann nicht mehr ich kann einfach
nicht mehr
[Musik]
es geht einfach nicht mehr von daher
würde ich die heutige episode minecraft
mit lukas auch beenden meine lieben
freunde es tut mir leid dass hier jetzt
quasi gar nicht so richtig voran
gegangen ist allerdings wird die nächste
folge dafür auch eine minecraft höhen
folge sein
die kommen morgen abend online um 20 uhr
tragt es euch vettel den kalender ein es
wird beschissen
[Musik]